Well, I'd really better
start, I can infer,
I think from looking around the room that
there is either post paper depression
at work or that having
read written the paper, uh,
is scarcely had time to read a 15
page labyrinthine essay by law call.
Um, that's unfortunate. Uh,
and I hope you're able to make up for
it soon. And those of you who, uh,
are here today,
uh,
can take such notes as you can figure
out how to take and then go back to the
text of Laconia and try to
make use of them. Uh, I, uh,
it is a pity that not everyone's here,
but we'll fair forward.
Nevertheless. Uh, now there
is an obvious link between,
uh,
the work of Peter Brooks that you read
last time and this particular essay of
Laconia, uh, which of course I'd
like to begin by underlining.
It has to do with the part
of the argument of Lacan,
which probably is most accessible to you
after your tour through structuralism
and related Isms and which,
uh,
in a way I think really can be used to
anchor a certain understanding of luck
call. Uh, and it's something
I am going to spend a walk,
want to spend a lot of time
with in the long run today.
And then a case Brooks understood,
uh,
the fictional texts,
the co and the completed
fictional narrative as a
sustaining of desire through a
series of day two or detours, uh, um,
inadequate and improper and points
overcome a resulting in a continuation of
desire, uh, resulting in a proper ending.
That is to say something corresponding
to what Freud understood as the desire of
the organism to die in its own way,
uh,
and not according to the modification
or pressure of something from without.
Uh, and this sequence of day to, uh,
in the elaboration of a narrative plot,
Brooks called Matana me in a way that by
this time we ought to recognize as what
happens,
uh,
in the putting together of signs along
the axis of combination as it's described
by [inaudible],
but Brooks remarks also that at the
same time there is a binding of this
sequence of signs of events.
In the case of a plot,
there is a binding of these signs.
There is an effect of unity,
a feeling that the experience one
has in reading a fictional plot is an
experience of unity. And this
effect, uh, he calls metaphor.
That is to say our sense of the
unity of a fictional pro plot.
We understand as metaphor some kind
of identity or self identity or close
correspondence in the
meaning of the variety of,
of events that we have encountered results
in a unity that can be understood in
metaphorical terms. Uh, in other words,
something like what Y'all cups and
calls the poetic function has been super
imposed on the med anemic,
uh,
access of combination in such a
way that the feeling of unity,
the sense of the recurrence of identity
in the signs used is something that we
can come away with.
And this a Brooks argues accounts for
our sense of the unity of the plot,
even as we understand
it to be a perpetual,
a form of the delay of desire.
Uh,
that's how I speak of the delay of
desire. That's most obvious. Of course,
at a marriage plot, a marriage plot
being the heart of fiction perhaps, uh,
and most immediately intelligible. But
of course, desire takes many forms.
There are many sorts of plot,
uh,
and they always do in one form or
another half to do in Brookson sense with
desire. Now, uh, I, I pause, uh,
in this way over Brooks because I think
you can see whatever frustration you may
also be feeling and encountering con,
I think you can see that the same basic
movement is at work in luck because
understanding of the unconscious,
the discourse of desire for luck car,
the perpetual deferral of
bringing into consciousness,
into being into presence,
the object of Desire Lacan to
hearkening back to Freud as Brooks does.
Hearkening back to the,
uh, distinction made, uh,
th th the, the, the, the,
the, the connection made, uh,
in Freud and thought and picked up by
[inaudible] between condensation and the
dream work and metaphor and the Dream
Work and displacement in the dream work
and my autonomy in the dream work.
This is central as well to luck argument,
the deferral of desire and for a la carte.
The impossibility ever of realizing
one's desire for a certain kind of other
that I'm going to be trying to identify
during the course of the lecture is
understood as much autonomy just as Brooks
understands the movement of metonymy
as a purpose, as not a
perpetual, uh, but a cyst,
a plot sustaining day tour
or deferral of the end.
So there's two, one finds
in desire and uh, in, in,
in Laconia and metaphor.
On the other hand,
he understands to be what he calls it.
One interesting point,
the quilting of the mat,
anemic chain,
the plan to copy Tom or quilting button
that suddenly holds together a sequence
of disparate signifiers in such a way
that a kind of substitution of signs as
opposed to a displacement of
science can be accomplished.
And we'll come back to this later on.
Uh,
in attempting to understand what Lacan
has to say about that line from victor
goes, Poem Boaz Asleep. Uh, the line,
his sheaves were not miserly nor spiteful.
We'll come back to that.
But in the meantime,
the point of Lacan and what makes a lot
cause reading of desire different from
Brooks's.
And indeed,
what makes his reading of desire different
from that of anyone who thinks of
these structuralist issues
in psychoanalytic terms as
that Laca really doesn't
believe that we can ever
have what we desire.
He has no doubt that we
can have what we need.
He makes the fundamental distinction
between having what we desire and having
what we need. The distinction is often
put, and when you read a Slovak g Zach,
next week, you'll see who makes a
much more central point of this.
It's often put as the distinction
between the big other. And uh,
later on we'll talk about why
it's big, uh, the big other,
which one can never appropriate
as an object of desire.
It is perpetually and always
elusive. And the OBC j petite, ah,
the little, uh, object of desire, uh,
which is not really an
object of desire at all,
but is available to satisfy
need socio biologically.
You can get what you need
a psychoanalytically,
you cannot get what you desire.
Now,
the obvious gloss here I think,
um, is the rolling stones. Uh,
if,
uh,
Lacan were the rolling stones and he'd
had slightly rewritten the famous refrain
by saying, you can never
get what you want, right.
But sometimes if you
try and you got to try,
I mean, even for what you
need, you've got to hear it.
You can't just sit there
sometimes if you try,
you can get what you
need. And so, and, and I,
I'm sure that a Mick Jagger had many
sticky fingers in the pages of Lacan in
order to be able, in order to be able
to make that important distinction.
Um,
but I think it's one that perhaps you
might want to salt away the next time you
feel confused about the distinction
between desire and need.
Uh, now obviously it'd be great
if we could just stop there,
but we do have to get a little closer
to the text and try to figure out why in
these terms given to us by Lacan terms,
both structuralist and psychoanalytic,
we have to figure out why this
distinction prevails, uh, and, and,
and what it amounts to. So we,
we soldier on. Uh, first of all,
let me just say a couple of things
in passing. There's, there is,
there is for humanistic studies
more than one Jacques Lacan.
There is the luck call for
literary studies who I think
is very well represented
by the text we have before us,
even though some of his most important
ideas are only hinted at in this text.
For example, we hear nothing in
this text about his famous, uh,
triadic distinction among the real,
the imaginary and the symbolic.
This is something we can't really explore,
uh,
with only this text before us.
And there's only the slightest hint at
the very end of the essay on the last
page of the distinction I've just made
between the big other and the object
Patea we'll have lots of time to think
about that because it's central to the
essay of Dziedzic that you read next week.
But for literary studies,
focusing on the structuralist
legacy for a lot call, uh,
this is an exemplary selection,
but there's also the lock car.
Perhaps a more current Lacan,
one better known,
perhaps even to some of
you have film studies,
the [inaudible] of the gays,
uh,
the complicated dialectic of the gaze,
which does very much
involve up negotiating the
distinctions among the real,
the imaginary and the symbolic.
And as I say, this luck, Huh?
We're obliged largely to leave aside,
uh,
if only because of the selectivity
of what I've given you to read.
Uh, but as I say, these are,
these are lock call, uh,
luck cause with very,
with,
with quite different emphases
overlapping only to a certain degree.
Now the other thing I want to say in
passing explains some of their other
strange tone of this essay.
You notice that Laca is just
sort of bristling with hostility,
uh, and of course as well,
condescension of all the big egos.
And in our syllabus, this is by far
the biggest and we, and you know,
it's just something we have to live
with and come to terms with. Uh,
but the condescension isn't just toward
the natural stupidity of all the rest of
us.
It's toward,
in particular what he takes to be the
distortion of the legacy of Freud by most
of his psychoanalytic contemporaries,
particularly the international
psychoanalytic association,
many members of whom were the so
called American ego psychologist.
Now what does an ego psychologist,
it's somebody who begins
as Lacan does too.
And this is something
we'll want to come back to.
It's somebody who begins with
Freud's famous proposition,
vo s Var,
Zol Zine where it was there I should be.
And other words out of the
raw materials of the ID, it,
it s in the unconscious,
the ego.
That is to say the capacity of the human
organism to develop into its maturity
should arise.
In other words,
they relationship between
instinctual drives and,
uh,
the proper inhibitions of human or adult
consciousness should be a progressive
one.
And the purpose of psychoanalysis,
the purpose of bringing people beyond,
uh,
their entrapment in the
various infantile stages, uh,
or beyond,
uh,
their entrapment in some
form or another of neurosis.
The idea of progress or development
in psychoanalysis has to do with the
emergence and reinforcement of the ego.
Huh?
Hates this idea.
And there isn't.
He hates it is because that idea of the
emergence of a stable and mature ego is
presupposed by the idea that there is
such a thing as stable human subjectivity.
In other words,
that there is such a thing
as consciousness from
which are communicated and
linguistic and other sorts of systems
derive laca takes a completely different
view of consciousness.
And this of course is something
to which we will turn in a moment.
But the basic disagreement and the
source of his most intense hostility
throughout this essay,
uh,
concerns the question whether or not
there is for each of us a stable and by
implication unique subjectivity.
We are not each other.
We suppose ourselves. Indeed we
complain when we think about ethics,
uh, of our, about our
isolation from each other.
We suppose ourselves to be all
together individual. Uh, uh,
whereas for a lot car,
um,
there is a kind of
continuousness in consciousness.
The reason for which I'll explain
at which is not absolute, uh,
in the long run.
And this essay you will find,
and I hope to be able to understand this
as a kind of turn in his argument in
the long run.
In this essay,
you will find that Lacan does actually
hold out a limited sense of individual
subjectivity, not as, not really
as autonomous subjectivity,
not something that can,
uh, that, that, that,
that can authorize a sense of
free will or power of agency,
but a,
a way in which the simplest owing simply
to the complexity of the unconscious,
a way in which each of us,
uh, as it were and habits,
a slightly different
form of that complexity.
Lacan goes that far in the direction
of the subject or of subjectivity,
but refuses the idea that the subject
that is something that can emerge from
analysis,
a analysis or in the case of,
I suppose most of us simply
through maturation as a stable,
coherent, uh, uh, well organized, uh,
a sense of self and identity.
All right,
let's start then with the one piece of
really solid clinical work that Lacan
ever did.
Uh,
la cause a psycho psycho analytic
philosophy is as he would be the first to
admit and even sort of tearfully to
endorse, uh, largely speculative.
That is to say he works,
uh,
in depth with philosophical and
literary materials. He is, uh,
uh, not glued to the analysts chair. Uh,
he is a notoriously impatient
with his annual exams,
uh, and uh, is uh,
very interested in matters of analysis
either in on the one hand shortcuts or on
the other hand,
uh,
championing Freud's late essay
analysis terminable or interminable,
uh,
taking the side.
That analysis is just obviously such
as the complexity of the thing in
terminable,
but they want really solid piece of
clinical research that Lacan did.
Uh,
and that is accepted as part of the
psychoanalytic psychoanalytic lore is his
work that he did in the
1930s on the mirror stage.
And that worked actually does generate
the system of ideas that [inaudible] has
to offer.
So what is the mirror stage?
A baby in the anal phase,
that is to say no longer identifying
with the abreast with the breast of the
mother, but aware of a sense
of difference between, uh,
whatever it might be. And that
otherness, which is out there,
a baby views itself in the mirror.
And you know, I mean, maybe it views
itself like this, right? It, it,
it can only crawl, you
know, it can barely touch.
It's knows it can't feed itself and it,
and,
and it's the actual nature of its body.
It's still frag fragmented and
disorganized. It lacks coordination.
And in fact,
it lacks in any ordinary
sense of the term uprightness.
But you know, let's say it's looking
at itself in the mirror like this.
And so, you know, what it
sees is something like this.
It sees, in other words,
it sees something which is coherent,
coordinated at really rather
handsome. Yo, you know, it,
it says, wow, you know,
I'm, I'm okay. Uh, and, and,
and it acknowledges itself to be at,
recognizes itself to be,
it's the object of the mother's desire,
right?
And that is the moment in which it no
longer identifies with the breast but
thinks of itself as the object of
the desire of another because of,
because it's so pleased with itself. So
somebody's gotta desire me, you know,
it's probably mom, you know,
so, so, so, so there it is. Uh,
and this is,
and this is the moment
of the mirror stage.
Now what happens after that,
and by the way,
the rather wonderful epigraph
from Leonardo Davinci,
which begins your essay is all about this.
What happens after that is rather tragic.
The baby falls into language
and in the moment of and,
and, and, and I'm going to come back
in a minute to the whole question.
Why is it language that does this in the
moment at which it falls into language?
It no longer sees itself as the ideal.
I, that's Eda. I'll ish
in Freud's language.
It no longer sees itself as the ideal eye,
but it comes into the recognition that
it doesn't even have its own name,
let alone and identity it
has the name of the father.
It sort of doesn't have
the Phallus of the father.
And it begins to recognize
competition in desire.
And it begins to recognize that what it
itself desires is not accessible in a
kind of mutuality of desire.
And that it is,
it has no choice but to admire while at
the same time envying and indeed forming
as an object desire because
that's what it lacks the father.
And that's the sense in
which, uh, but, but it's,
it's the father only in a
phantasmagoric sense in [inaudible],
the object of desire can
be just absolutely anything
depending on the course of
the, of, of, of, of the,
of, of the unraveling of a,
of, of a, the men anemic sequence, uh,
that desire follows.
But this is what Lacan associates
with the oedipal phase.
And that's why I say
in passing the father,
and it does have something to do
with luck cause revision of Freud.
Uh, uh, in saying that the object of lack,
the object of lack,
that perpetually motivates desire.
The desire for what one
lacks is not an all physical.
I mean, if you make that mistake,
you're right back in, in, you know,
sort of mindless Freud, hedonism.
You know, it's not the penis.
It is on the contrary something which
is by nature symbolic something which is
an ego ideal.
That is to say,
but no longer oneself.
That is to say no longer what one has,
but what through the gap
opened up by language.
One recognizes that one lacks.
And so it takes a variety of,
let's just say fellow go centric forms,
uh,
in film criticism.
Some of you may know the essay,
the Lacanian Essay of Laura Molavi in
which the female object of the spectators
desire or gays dressed in a sheath
dress is actually just like the baby.
Just like anything else.
It is this. In other words,
it is sort of, despite being obviously
an incredibly different kind of thing,
nevertheless,
in symbolic terms,
the Fallis all right. Now,
so the question then is,
why is it that it's language that does
this lacoss speaks of the impossibility
of realizing a and object of desire?
Because the metronomic structure of
desire follows what he calls an ace in
[inaudible] course,
a syntonic meaning the line which curves
toward the lion it wants to meet but
never reaches it.
And there's a kind of an underlying
punning sense in that word of the met
anemic, uh, course of desire
not revealing the symptom.
It's a symbiotic in that sense as well.
Uh,
the only thing that can reveal the
symptom is those moments of quilting. Uh,
the, the moments at the plant
to copy tall when metaphor,
as Lakana says on two different occasions
in the essay reveals the symptom.
So this is what happens when you can't
get ever when you can't
ever get what you want.
And the question is,
but don't worry because you can always
have what you need as long as you try. Uh,
so the question is why
does language do this?
What is it about language that
introduces this problematic beyond repair
call?
It begins with an,
he begins the essay with a claim
about the Freud in unconscious,
a claim which he takes.
He says from the interpretation of dreams
where Freud speaks of the relationship
between condensation and displacement
in the dreamwork Lacan says,
the unconscious is structured like a
language that's perhaps the most single
expression that people take away
from luck on. And rightly so,
because it is again, foundational and, uh,
what we need to understand, uh, if
we're to get, uh, get along with him.
The unconscious is structured like
a language. Now what does this mean?
It means that the UNCA, he doesn't say
the unconscious is a language, by the way.
And he doesn't say that he means the
unconscious is structured exclusively like
human language.
He means that the unconscious
is structured like a
semiotic system. And in fact,
he draws from Freud's
interpretation of dreams.
The idea that the way the dream work
works and the way everyday life and Freud
sense of the psychopathology of
everyday life works is like a rebus.
In other words, one of those
puzzles in which you can find the,
an underlying sentence.
If you figure out how to put
together drawings, numbers,
syllables,
and other words,
a sequence of signs taken from
different semiotics systems,
uh, that can put themselves
together into a meaning.
That's how Lacan understands
the dream work and the, uh,
the movements of
consciousness, uh, to go. They,
the unconscious then is structured like
a language which is not the same thing
as to say it is a language now,
okay.
Structured like a language.
This means,
and this is where there is this
enormous gulf between Loc and most other
practitioners of psychoanalysis,
the unconsciousness is not in that case
to be understood as the seat of the
instincts. It's not to be
understood as something prior.
In other words,
to those forms of derivative articulation,
those forms of articulation emerging
through maturity that we're accustomed to
call language. If the unconscious
is structured like a language,
then it,
the ID s itself is
precisely the signifier,
the signifier that is that,
that that emerges as language.
Not,
not that that is foundational to language
because luck Han's point like the
point of many other people in our
syllabus is not that is not that language
expresses thought.
Not at all that language
expresses thought,
but that language constitutes thought.
That language brings
thought consciousness,
a sense of things into being that
this is articulated through language.
Now this of course brings
us immediately to um,
certain issues, uh, of
conflict that lock car has,
not just with other
forms of psychoanalysis,
but with a whole philosophical tradition.
If you are a materialist,
in other words,
if you believe that things come
first and consciousness comes second,
that is to say if you're a Marxist,
if you, if, if you believe that,
uh,
that that consciousness ideology call it
what you will is determined by existing
material circumstances.
As one says,
you can't very well think that existing
material circumstances are produced by
language. Whoa. You know, and if by
the same token you're a positivist,
if you believe that the meaning of
things is something that is expressed by
language, something that language
is brought into being to express,
then also you're giving priority to
things to that which is behind language to
that which gives rise to language rather
than as Lacan does giving priority to
language and he actually attacks both
the Marxist tradition and the positive
tradition at various points in
your text. Uh, the, uh, the,
the sideways blow at at
Marxism is on page 1130,
the right hand column, the
size, what the sideways blow it.
Positivism is on page 1132,
uh, the right hand column.
I don't want to pause, uh, to quote
them. Uh, but uh, you can, you,
you can go to them in,
in your text.
So what is it?
Id s what is what that which
is normally called, uh,
the instinctual drives, the
Id, you know, that, you know,
these are sort of the
UN unmediated, uh, the,
the unmediated wish for something.
Well,
lock on says it is nothing other
than the signifier. He says,
what do I mean by literalism?
How else can I mean it except literally
it is the letter that is to say
consciousness begins with the letter.
Remember Levy Strauss saying
in the text quoted by Derrida,
remember Levy Strauss sang.
The language doesn't come into
being just a little bit at a time.
One day there is no language and the next
day there is language which is to say
suddenly there is a way of conferring
meaning on things and that way of convert
conferring meaning on
things is differential.
That is to say it introduces the
arbitrary nature of the sign and the
differential relations among signs which
are featured in the work of so Seward
so it has so it is for
lock off the letter,
is that not which is brought
into being to express things.
Not that which is brought into being in
the service of the ego to discipline and
civilize the ID but rather is it itself.
That is to say it is the beginning.
In the beginning was the
word in the beginning was
the letter which disseminates
consciousness through the signifying
system that it makes available.
Now. Actually, I'm hoping
that in saying these things,
you find me merely and, and, and
rather dull. He repeating myself, uh,
saying things that I've said
before because it seems to
me that this is the part
of, of lock core, which is
accessible and which, uh, is,
is, is central to the sorts of
things that we've been talking about,
which I rather imagine you must
be getting used to by this time.
Yaka Epson lock car shares a structuralist
understanding of how the unconscious
discourses he accepts Jaak Upson's
distinction between metaphor and Mytonomy.
And he sees the cooperative
building up relationship of matter,
metaphor and metonymy in the discourse
of the unconscious and of the
psychopathology of everyday day life in
much the same way that [inaudible] does.
Remember Yacob son, uh,
associates matter for an autonomy,
not just with poetry and prose,
not just with certain kinds of style,
but actually with pathologies.
Uh,
and it's extreme forms metaphor and
my autonomy as manifest in linguistic
practice,
uh,
take the form of Aphasias and
so yuck as Lakoff points out.
And so y'all cups in
two is concerned with,
with something sort of built in hard
wired in the way in which language works.
Uh, in an as the unconscious, uh,
that in its extreme forms is aphasic and
always expresses itself in tendencies,
either met anemic or
metaphoric. Now, of course,
he also draws on,
so sir,
but as your editor rightly
points out and a footnote, uh,
the way in which he reads.
So sewer,
the signifier,
the big signifier over the signified,
the little rather insignificant signified.
Because after all,
what does it signified matter?
You can never,
you can never cross the bar.
All right to get to it,
you are barred from it. The
signified, uh, is you know,
that what, which from which you
are forever excluded. And we'll,
we'll go into lock cons. Example of
the examples of this in a minute.
This is actually quite
different from so sewers, uh,
signified over the signifier,
uh,
anchored by a kind of mutuality
whereby it's never a question,
uh, what generates what, uh,
but rather a question. And, but,
but, and which has in common,
I think with a lot so-called
algorithm only, in fact,
the bar itself,
the fact that the relationship between
signifier and signified or signified and
signifier is an arbitrary one that can't
be crossed by evoking anything natural
in the nature of the signified that calls
forth the signifier there they agree,
but as to what produces what.
So Sarah is agnostic about it
and Lacan incests that the big s,
uh,
is that which generates the signified
that from which any possibility of
grasping a signified, uh,
arises and derives. So,
so Lacoste Algorithm is act is
in fact rather difficult, uh,
different from, uh, so
sewers diagram now, okay,
let's, let's exemplify this, uh,
by going back to what I said about the
red light, right? Because here too,
I think we'll have continuity,
right?
The red light over a door is a signifier
which has a great deal to do with
desire, right? Uh, this week,
this we take for granted the reds,
the red light in other contexts has
nothing to do with desire, but the,
a signifier,
a red light over a door suggests desire.
But desire for what? Well, we
think we know desire for what,
but look at the signifier.
Desire for the door does,
I mean,
what is the relationship between the
signifier and what would seem to be the
signified? Right? That's
not what you desire.
You don't desire the door. And it's the
same with on a farm. Right? You know?
So what is this [inaudible] a farm.
Well, okay, the little girl says,
we've arrived at gentlemen and the little
boy says we've arrived at ladies. Well,
that seems to be quite healthy,
right? We're on our way. We're, we're,
we're on our way to something like
heteronormative desire. Great,
terrific. But wait a minute, this,
I'm here. Right? What, what does,
um, what does that have to
do with the price? I mean,
the only thing you can do with,
even behind this door is restore
your personal comfort. I mean,
it has nothing to do with, it
has nothing to do with right, or,
or anything else for that matter.
Uh, and if it's the, and if the,
the visible signified,
uh, is in question, well,
in what sense can we call this door?
Um,
right and it's the same with farm and uh,
there is in any case,
uh, in uh, in La Cause Anecdote, um,
the wonderful existence
or the railroad tracks,
which for him constitutes the bar.
That is to say that owing to the nature
of language whoring to the arbitrary
relation of the signifier to the signified
the little boy and little girl who
are, who are wonderful characters right
out of no buck off's, Ata, I don't know,
I don't know if any of
you know that novel,
but the little boy is a
sort of a little genius,
obviously Lacan but his sisters even
smarter than he is, she says, you know,
just like a character in the Volkov.
But both this little boy and
little girl are barred from desire,
from their desire because they have,
they are already putting up
with a substitute precisely
in so far as they seem
to be on track towards something like,
uh,
the heteronormative expression of desire.
It's not an expression of desire at all.
It's an expression of need because they
are not able to bring into being or
consciousness or before themselves.
The object of desire
indicated by the signifier.
The signifier is always displaced from
the object of desire and precisely the
ways that are borne out
diagrammatically in, in these formulas.
All right, so, um, what then is desire?
Well, perhaps we've
covered it. It is the, uh,
endless deferral of that which cannot
be signified in the Metta Nimic movement
of discourse or of dreaming or of the way
in which the unconscious functions and
Lacan is very ingenious in showing,
I think convincingly showing us how it
is that we get from one signifier to
another. In other words, how, what he
calls the chain of the signifier works.
You have a series of concentric rings,
but each concentric ring is made up
of a lot of little concentric rings,
which Hook on to associated
surrounding signifiers,
uh, in ways that could be variable. This,
I think very nicely up re diagrams,
so serious sense of the associate
of structure of the vertical axis.
That is to say,
of the sin chronic moment of language,
the way in which some signifiers naturally
cluster with other signifiers and not
just one group of signifiers,
but a variety of groups of signifiers,
but don't all naturally cluster with just
any or all signifiers so that you get
associated clusters in
the access of selection.
And they are indicated by this.
And as the chain of signifiers unfolds,
um,
the one or another of these possible
associations links on and remember all of
these, I mean, all of
these signifiers, uh,
are made up in turn, have a chain
of, uh, of concentric circles.
So I think this is a rather good way
of understanding the unfolding of,
of, of autonomy. Now every once
in awhile you get metaphor.
Whoa. You know, and it's a moment
to be celebrated in lock con, uh,
because it's as he says,
poetic. And it is also,
as he says in a number of places,
the manifestation,
the only possible manifestation of
the symptom. What is the symptom?
The awareness of the lack of an object
of desire expressed in a displaced
manner. That is to say, expressed in
a manner which is not, however said,
it's completely Upfest gatory of
the lack of the object of desire.
And it just sort of caught up
in my endless battling, uh,
but rather is that moment of pause in
which there is a gathering together of
signifiers and ultimately a substitution
of one signifier for another in such a
way that one says, Aha, I
see it. I can't grasp it.
I can't have it. But I see it.
I see the object of desire.
I see what has been displaced by
the very act of signification.
That's what he calls metaphor.
And he sees matter for as appearing
at these planned to copy. Tom,
think of this as a quilt.
Think of this as quilting.
What are your column
quilting, quilting, those,
you know what I'm talking
about? Quilting, nuts.
Pins knit. No, not needles.
That's what you make a quilt with.
Uh, uh, uh, those little buttons,
quilting buttons, right. You
know, that's what a quilt is
like. He's, it's, it's, it's,
it's filled with something and then,
and then the,
the stuffing is held in place by buttons,
right?
So the stuffing of men and [inaudible]
signification is held in place usefully
for the analyst, for the
reader, for the interpreter,
by these quilting buttons
or plan to copy Tom.
And so the example that,
Yuck Yuck,
I'm sorry that luck comp
gives, uh, is as I say,
he gives several examples there.
There are the wonderful dazzling ratings,
both the four lines from Valerie and
of the one line from Victor Hugo,
I focus on the ego because it's a
little easier just the one line. Um,
he says there is something that happens
in this line which is metaphoric and he,
I'm delighted that he uses the word
sparks. In other words, the metaphoric,
the presence of the metaphor is a spark.
I remember I was talking about in Wolfgang
[inaudible] the need to gap a spark
plug, spark plug. In other words,
the need to have a certain
distance between two points
in order for the spark to
happen. If it's too close, it doesn't
happen. You can, you just share it out.
And if it's too distant,
it doesn't happen because you
know the distance is too great.
So the spark that lock cause
talking about is the relationship.
His sheaves were neither miserly nor
spiteful as the relationship between Boaz
and his sheets because
the shades themselves,
which give of themselves,
you know, you know,
just as certain other things we could
mention give of itself, the sheet,
the shades,
the themselves,
which give of themselves and certainly
are not miserly or spiteful for that
reason. They're generous,
they're open, they give, they
feed us, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera. Um, uh,
are supposed in Matana me to
indicate that Boaz is like that.
Oh, look at the munificence
of Boaz is crop. You know,
it's neither miserly north spiteful,
but as Lacan points out,
you know,
the miserliness and spitefulness
comes back in an unfortunate way,
precisely in that word, his, the word.
Because if he is a possessor of the Sheaf,
he is, he, he, this involves, uh,
perhaps sort of the hole as it were,
structure of capitalist or
Darwinian competition, uh,
and involves,
at least in an underlying way,
all the elements of
friction, if you will, uh,
and competitive envy, spite, if you will,
that seem to have been
banished. Uh, from the sentence.
In other words,
metaphorically speaking,
Boaz returns in his absence,
he substitutes.
He is substituted for by
the expression his sheets.
The possessive means that he is not
the things that he said to be met,
an ethnically speaking and the shades
themselves are precisely what he is in the
oedipal phase.
That is to say precisely what he is if
he is objectified by a baby looking at
him, but at the same time, uh, not at all,
uh, what or where we expected
him to be. In other words,
they plan to copy ta of the sentence
of the line is the substitution of his,
of boy ads for his sheaves
and his sheaves for boys.
The,
so,
so the line has both a mat anemic reading
and a metaphoric reading here I think
you can see lacan sense of the relation
between metaphor and Matana me hovering
between that of York,
Epson or Brooks and that of demand,
because there seems to be an underlying
irreducible tension between reading the
sentence as the reading the line as though
it says Ma Boaz was generous and free
of spite and rating the line as though
it said boy as just necessarily because
he's one who possesses something.
A person who has the
characteristics of miserliness,
miserliness and spitefulness and other,
the tension in other words seems to
me to be in Lacan and irreducible one,
so that at least in that regard,
we can place him closer to Lacan than
we have a to say Brooks or [inaudible],
which isn't to say that [inaudible] is
not the primary and central influence on
lock cons way of thinking about
the access of combination, the,
the, uh, the appearance of metaphor
on the access of combination.
They way in which we can identify these
quilting buttons on the axis of common
is nothing other than what Jakobsen
Yacob son said and meant when he said the
poetic function is the transference of
the principle of equivalents from the
access of selection to the
axis of combination. All right,
so this, uh, this, uh, I'm not saying in,
in speaking, in passing of this
sort of irreducible conflict,
one senses between autonomy and
metaphor. Here, I'm not saying that, uh,
that,
uh,
Jaco Epson is not the primary influence
behind lock cons thinking in this
regard. All right? Now, Lacan says,
language is a rebus says,
I've said, and he says,
the movement of the signifier,
which is the movement of desire,
is the articulation of a lack.
That is to say it is in the
impossibility of as the,
uh, as, as, as certain kinds of
language philosophers would say,
of making the signifier hook
onto the signifier signified,
or as we might say,
hook up with the signified.
The impossibility of doing that,
uh,
is precisely the impossibilities
of realizing and object of desire.
So all of this, uh, all of this
should I hope now be clear.
So at some of the,
some of the consequences are that language
and the most obvious consequence is,
and this isn't the first time or last
time that we will live encounter this in
various vocabularies and context
is that language thinks me odd.
Page 11, 42, the right
hand column for example,
I think where I am not therefore I am
where I do not think that is to say that
which,
uh,
that which brings my thinking
into being is not present to me.
It, it, it is the letter.
It is the signifier which is
perpetually, uh, the signified.
I'm sorry to say, I meant to say
which is, which perpetually evades us.
Uh, and which cannot
possibly be present to us.
I am not present to myself.
I cannot be present to myself because
what is present is the way in which my
self comes into being in discourse,
which cannot identify me.
They cannot identify me,
uh,
either as subject or,
in a phase of narcissism or a supposing
I can somehow or another re imagined
myself in the mirror phase
as an object of desire.
All right. So, uh, I
actually think that, um,
without quite having meant to,
I've pretty much pretty much exhausted,
uh, what I have to say, an
outline about luck call.
I haven't said nearly enough about the
relationship between desire and need as
it plots itself in our
actual lives and in fiction.
Because the extraordinary thing about
it is it's not just a slogan from the
rolling stones or from Lacan
as we think about it, you know,
not that we're not happy
with, uh, with our,
with the, our relationship,
with the things that we need.
Obviously we are.
But the extraordinary thing about it
is that we recognize in our lives,
in the magical world of film that
is to say the world of illusion,
deliberately promoted by film.
Uh,
and in fiction we recognize the
absolutely central significance of this
distinction.
That's what's so wonderful and
amazing about the essay by Jijak,
you'll be reading for next week called
courtly love, which I, which I love,
uh, and which, which,
which is headlines which features
readings of a series of films,
uh,
in which the law Keynesian distinction
between the impossibilities ever of
achieving the big other. By
the way, there seem to be,
there are times in various kinds of
fictional plots in which you can actually
have the object of desire.
But what always happens in plots
like that is that the unconscious,
the psyche finds ways of rejecting it.
You know,
I can't have that. It's my brother
or I can't, I can't have that.
It is in one form or another
forbidden, right? In other words,
it is in actuality,
in the way in which the psyche works,
uh, according to the
structure of the films, uh,
Jijak undertakes to analyze.
And he's so profused and examples that
he really does leave us feeling that
there's a kind of universality
in what he's saying. Uh, yeah,
there are all kinds of,
there are all kinds of, uh,
object choices that can
happen and do happen.
And may even seem satisfactory,
but the,
those are all objects of Jay Patea,
whereas the big other,
the, the, that, that,
which is the true object of desire
is something that will prevent,
that will provecho perpetually
evade a possession. Okay.
So next time we're actually talking
about the anxiety of influence and Harold
bloom.
And then in the ensuing lecture,
we'll return in a way to lock con
when we take up Deleuze Guattari and,
uh, slower. Dziedzic. Thank you.